では よろしくお願いします yāva
devā anatthāya ñataṃ bālassa jāyati. Hanti bālass
a sukhaṃ saṃuddhamassa vipāta
やん
yāva devā anatthāya ñataṃ bālassa jāyati. Hanti bālas
sa sukhaṃ saṃuddhamassa
vipātaやん という
あのー またこの この愚か者というね
無知な人って誰ですか？というタイトルの章ですね
だからこのいろいろ いろんなタイプの無知な人のことを説明されてあります
今日もそんなに難しくはないんですけどね
そんなにと言ったって意味がないんですね
難しくはないんです yāva
devā anatthāya ñataṃ bālassa jāyati. bālassaって愚か者にñataṃというのは知ったもの
いわゆる知識ですね 勉強したもの
あるいはでき とにかく能力のこと
愚か者が何か能力 知識
勉強したならばanatthāya
それは不幸のためになるんだよと
この人の 愚か者が何を学んで
何を訓練して 何に上達したっても
かえってそれはその人の不幸になるんだよということなんです
愚か者が知ったことは
その人の破壊になりますよと Hanti
bālassa sukhaṃ san
その知ったことは このbālassa
その愚か者の あの sukhaṃ
sanというのは良いところ
何か残っているならば
良いところ いい性格 それも壊して壊していくんですよ uddhamassa
vipātaやん uddhaṃ
というのは頭のてっぺんのこと
でも頭のことなんですね
頭 首が落ちますよという言葉でも
それは表現であって 全部破壊になりますよという意味なんですね
いわゆる見込みないように壊れてしまいます uddhaṃ
というのは一番トップの
もう生命という 命ということなんですが
そこまでなくなっていきますよと
もうどうしようもないんだよという意味なんですね
だからポイントは 頭の悪い人がね
頭の悪い人は別にいいんですよ
性格が悪くないんだからね
そういうものじゃない
愚か者なんです 頭の良し悪しの問題じゃないんです
で 性格的に悪い人がね
愚か者と言うんですよ
勉強できる人とできない人は区別しません
愚か者にも結構勉強できるんです
これはやっぱり性格のことで
性格的に良くできている人が
たとえ文字一つ読めなくても愚か者ではありません
性格的にできてない人が
たとえ世界一流の学者であろうとも愚か者なんです
だから仏教は別にもう何ができるかということはあんまり人を評価しませんね
それは評価に値しませんね
例えば工学をやっているんだと
医学をやっているんだからといって
どちらの方が偉いでしょうかと
どうでもいいでしょうにね
工学も医学も何もやらないで
ただ土木作業をやっている人がいるんだよと
誰でもただ単に何か職業があって生活しているだけで
もうそれぞれ役に立ちますから生きていられるし
役に立たないことを勉強したっても
誰も買ってくれませんだから
それで生活はできないだけで
ですから学ぶことっていうのはそんなに大げさなことじゃないんですよ
例えばもう教育はあんまり面白くないんだと
やりたくないんだというならば
それで結構ですよ その代わりに別なことをやればいいんです
だから 高校卒業するかしないかっていうことは問題じゃなくて
良い人間か悪い人間かっていうことは大きな問題なんです
それで性格悪い人に限って結構勉強しますよ
めちゃくちゃすごい競争して
とにかくもう上上上目指していくんですね
とにかく自分がなんとかしてでも上に行きたいだけであって
それによって人類に何かしてあげようとかね
それはないんです どうやってたくさん給料もらって
もう退職してからももっと給料もあって
もう天下りできるのかというね
法律を犯しても裁かれないようにとかね
で まあそういうことでも
例えば談合をやったっても
談合する会社が裁かれるのであって
談合をやらせた側がものすごい安全でしょ
その極秘のデータを与えてね
談合をやらせた人々はもう裁かれません
裁けません その人 もしかすると裁判に行って証言するかもしれません
これは決してけしからんなことであるとかね
そこまで言うかもしれません
ですから この なんでしょうかね
性格悪い人といっても
いわゆる愚か者といっても
勉強できないというわけじゃない
それをよく覚えてほしいんです
仏教で愚か者 愚か者というのは普通
認識がアビコベで 例えば自分の利益だけ考えることも認識がアビコベでしょうに
全く愚か者なんですね
自分の利益だけで成り立ちません
で すべて交換条件で世の中成り立っているのであって
この交換条件はもう壊して
自分だけ特別に得をしようということでも
自然法則を壊しているんですよ
だから愚か者なんです
例えば あんまりよく勉強してない人が一生懸命重労働で頑張って頑張って頑張っても文句も言わないし
仕事はきついよと言えないので
お前は勉強しなかったんだからしょうがないでしょうと逆襲されますからね
だから控えめで一生懸命仕事をして
ほとんど自分の労働力の半分ぐらいしか給料もらってないとかね
それでも文句言わないとか
愚か者じゃないんですよ
そういう人々は 国を 社会を支えているんですよ
道路工事したっても 夜やってるでしょうね
何人か何人か 全然立場も何もないので
そういう人々は誰も顔も知りません
名前も知りません だから
まあ隠れてもう外国人も仕事をしていますけどね
東京町の中 全部穴掘っていますけどね
どこでも潜っていきますからね
そういうのは誰が掘ったのかね
どんな大げさな大型の会社の名前ぐらい知ってますけど
会社は全然もうやってないんだからね
だからやっぱり普通の人間っていうのは
一番社会の役に立ってます
それで何か間違いあったら
すぐそういう人々は捕まるし
そういうことで このただ単に勉強して上々行っていて素晴らしい人やということは決してそうじゃないんです
逆にトップにいる人々っていうのは
まあかなり我が強くて
かなり人を潰して潰して
で 人の足を引っ張って
自分が人の頭に乗って踏みつけて上に上がるんですよ
だから そんなに素晴らしいということはないんです
だから愚か者っていうのは知識の問題ではありません
これは必ずしも性格的なことで
この性格が悪い人は危ないんです
その人々が知識得たりしたら
人類の迷惑なんです だからこの
社会っていうのは知識があれば昔は困っていたんですよ
知識がない時期ではね
で 迷信ばっかしで 一番昔はね
まあ田んぼがうまくできなかったら
それは神様のたたりではないかとか思ったりとかね
で 害虫が入ってきたら
これは神様のたたりではないかとか思ったりしていたりしてね
迷信ばっかしで で 困っていたんですね
しかし 今ほど自然災害はなかったんです
もうたまたままあ もうもしかすると年に一回とか
まあなんかもう凶作になったりとかしましたけどね
でもそれは何だとわからなかったしね
だからまあ 私たちの生き方悪かったんだから
神様が怒っているんだよと
一生懸命神様に拝んだり
お願い立てたり 雨が降らなかったら
もう我々の何か村の人々なんか悪いことしたんじゃないかなとかね
だから神様は怒っているんだと
一生懸命神様にお願いしてお願いして
雨降らしてくれとかね
そういう時期もあったんだけど
性格悪かったわけじゃないんですよ
しかし それで人間っていうのは
やっぱりこの知識っていうものがね
あったらもっと解放されるのではないかなということで
で 知識増やしたり調べたりはしました
そこで何から解放されたかというと
あの謙虚さ これがなくなったんです
それだけなんです 強欲になっただけ
昔の人は迷信はむちゃくちゃ迷信でしたかもしれませんけど
家を出る時でも 北から出るか南から出るかとかね
だから大変で まあ家の玄関がね
例えば南向きであって
今日は北向きに行かなくちゃいけないと
もう下がっていかなくちゃいけないんですからね
後ろに でないと出かけ出られませんからね
しかし そういう人々は我が強くないんですよ
すごく謙虚なんです 私には何の力もないんだからね
まあ恐れ多く生きていようではないかと
だからとても優しくて
木も皮も何でもかんでも自分にはちょっとすごいと見えるものは何でも拝む
拝んだりもするし 面白いこというのは
この小さな動物まで蛇とかカエルとかね
これまた幸福のシンボルにしていたんだから踏みつけてもいいんですけど
別にどうった力もあるわけじゃないし
それさえもしなかったんですよ
だからカエルも大変な幸福な動物で
蛇も幸福な動物で もう全部そうなんですね
だから家にカエルさんが来ると
なんとかいいことあるんだなと思うところで
人間っていうのは自我がそんなにできてないって意味なんです
で まあそれは完全にいいっていうことはないんだから
あれこれで迷信に足が引っ張られて生きていられない状態にも
ちょっと間違っちゃうとね
身動き身動きができなくなるんですからね
あまりにもそれに依存しちゃうと
だからお釈迦様はそういうところはよくよくおっしゃってますからね
こんな迷信に引っかかっちゃうとね
あんた方は損するんだよと
いうことは言ってはいる
おっしゃってはありますけどね
それで 俗世間の知識人たちがいろんな調べて調べて
いろんなことをやったりして
迷信一つ一つ一つ一つ破ってはいくんですね
まあもう 迷信破ってますかね
やっぱり はい それでこの自分には何でもできるぞというね
自然を支配することはできるんじゃないかと
そういう方向へ行って
もう何でも儲かりますよと
そういうことになって
とにかく強者がのみ生きるべきやという世界になってきたんですね
だから みんな一緒に生きていなくちゃいけないという時代から
いえ 強者にしか生きる権利がないんだと
勝ち組 負け組あるんだよと
負けた 負けたこと人のことは知ったものじゃないんだよと
いうことで何でも破壊していっちゃうんですね
それから人間の自由も破壊しましたし
今自由がないんです で
元に戻ったんです 昔も自由はあまりなかったんだからね
今は何の自由もない びっしり束縛された世界で生きていなくちゃいけない
思考の自由 もう言論の自由のところか
思考の自由さえないんです
今は 考える自由もないんです
我々は何考えるべきかということは
強者が教えてくれるんです
その通りに考えるしかないんです
別にそれは一応マインドコントロールしますから
本人は気づかないんですね
だから情報化社会っていうことはね
完全マインドコントロール社会っていうことなんです
ということなんです すごく鈴の種やと
この今 インターネットでな
みんないろんな自分の発言できるようになってしまって
これが大変困りましたと
すごく困ってます 強者たちは
だからそこもいろいろやってます
言論の自由がないないようにと
で アメリカなんかはブロック的でもちょこちょことでも変な
面白いことをいい加減なこと書いちゃうともう危ない
全部調べます で いわゆるこのある記事がありましたね
このテロということを言い訳にして
政府とFBIが個人のプライバシーをとことん侵害することに悪用しているんだよと
いわゆる人権っていうのはもうひとかけらもないと
どこかで訴えられて それを認めたことありますけど
まあはい それは悪かったと
悪かったと言って それで終わり
直しまた改良しますとはなかったんです
誰か誰か訴えたら それはすいません
それはすいませんでした
はい 終わり それからまたやる
やる側はみんな訴えようとしませんだからね
特にこの 英語でもこういう通信で書く場合は
今英語変わってますから
言葉書かないんですね
全く信号で信号はそのまま読むと文章になるんです
それで文章も完了して書かないんです
で どうせわかるものは書きません
で だからこの信号をうまく使っているかないかとかね
もしかすると信号で いろんなことを喋っているんではないかということで
このメールであまりもこの信号を使う人々はみんなチェックされているんです
信号ってどういうこと？暗号？ 暗号っていう意味ではないんですね
絵文字みたいな  絵文字は使いませんだけど
それは日本だけですね
絵文字っていうのは無意味です
何の意味もない 絵文字は何も伝わってきません
文章だからね 例えば FOR YOU あなたのためと FOR に 4つ 4 書くんですよ
だからフォーと読めばそれだけ
だから FOR は FO UR FOR なんですけど FOR
YOU 場合は FOR なんですけど
スペルはどうでもいいんです
発音で FOR と YOU
と YOU でしょ？書きません
U だけ書くんです 文字の U
だから 4 と U 文字の U があったら
これ FOR YOU なんです
これ上手な人は見事に書くんです
それから大文字使いません
ややこしいんですけど
I って私っていうことはいつでも大文字で書かなくちゃいけないのに
大文字は使いません ある文章を読んだんですけど
なんか商売の文章なんですよ
もう テレックスメッセージでしたけど
だからあまりたくさん文字は書けないし
もうなんとかなんとか
要求している品物がもうなんとか国に送りましたから
まあこれお金のこれこれあれとか
全部もうそういう信号みたいな略語で
だからそういうのをいっぱい使うと
まあ怪しいというね どれが管理していますね
ある女の人が裁判にかけられてましたね
学生なんですけど 誰かを殺すぞと書いたって
もう誰かと腹が立って
ただ書いただけなんですけどね
普通日常会話ではそんなことは平気で言いますけどね
まあだから結局は言論の思考の自由さえもなくなっていて
ブロックの時代になってきたら
まあそれは十分そのその国々にはそれいろんなチャネル消すことはできるんですよ
だから世界の情報に誰でもアクセスできるわけじゃないんです
いろんなものはもうアクセスできないように
そのその国がもう制限して
どんなやり方かわかりませんだけどね
例えばタイでは YOUTUBE は見れませんとかね
それを王様を侮辱したんだということでね
中国もいろいろものはね
カットするし アメリカはもっと酷くものすごい情報カットしてますけど
一番情報カットしてるのはもしかするとアメリカかもしれません
ソ連は何もカットしてないんです
むちゃくちゃなんです
まあどうしようもない
例えば犯罪的なね ことは
流す 流していいわけじゃないし
だからこういうのはもうどうにもならん世界だからね
そこでブログでみんな何書くかというと
自分の妄想 もう何の管理もなく気持ち悪い
人に言うものじゃないんです
精神的にイカれて病気なんです
だから書くは書くは書くは
私はブログという名前を聞いただけで気持ち悪い
一度もどちらにもアクセスしませんし
自分では書けません そんなにイカれてないんだと
これ何とか書いておかなきゃ落ち着きませんよと
時間があったらもうその時間私は寝ます
ブログ書くよりは ゲームでもやります
だから何かそれなりの立派なアイディアがあって
まあなかなか普通のチャンネルでは発表できるぐらいの力がないとかね
まあそれだったら まあそれはブログでいろんなね
のは出したってもよろしいし
そうではないんですから
やっぱり管理せざるを得ないということになってくるし
管理する場合はやっぱり強者が自分の目的で自分を管理したいものを管理する
犯罪的なものにしたっても
この国が決めた犯罪的なものは管理するんですけど
個人個人の間のことは管理しません
例えば日本で自殺願望の連中には
随分簡単にブログ作ってお互い仲良く話し合って
あの自殺することはできます
それは調べようとしない
利益ないんだから他のものは厳しいという
いわゆる強者が自分の利益のために管理するっていうことで
とにかく社会がね 発展していって
自由自由だと口先で言うだけなんですよ
昔の人は当然自由ではなかったんです
もう自然にやられちゃったんだからね
政府にしたって民主主義もなかったし
だからそれはもうある家族がずっと管理していて
それでそこら辺ではもうお互い殺し合いやってますから
まあ向こうは向こうでもう大変でしょうし
で 政治家が殺し合いやり始めちゃうと
一般人も強引に参加させちゃうしね
だから嫌で いや応なしにもう戦いに行かなくちゃいけないし
それで軍隊というふうに正式的な教育も訓練を受けているわけでもないんだから
ただいて殺すだけのことだから
本当に最悪なんですね
まあそういう不幸がありましてね
うまくいかなかったんですね
では 知識開発することによって人間が自由になった
かというと 結局は形が変わっただけ
自由がないんです それで言いたかったのは
この科学知識 技術 知識なんかを技術能力なんかを開発することによって
もう何でもできるんだぞという
このすごいエゴが出てきて
このエゴが出てきて  そのその強者が自分の利益のために全て使うんですね
それで全部壊れていくんです
もう取り返しできません
もう自然そのものまで壊しちゃったんです
昨日今日テレビで見たんですけど
イラクにこの新しい形のこのヘリでしたっけね
配備することにしましたと
それはあの もう安全性も世界ではもうこれほど完璧なものはいっぱい事故があったり起きたりして
なかなか大変でしたから
あの 直接サーッと上がったり降りたりする
すごいもうヘリですね
あのローターが 2つあって
これ両側飛行機の翼みたいな感じで 2つあって
だからそこを長いロータリーだから回すんだから
かなり幅横に取りますけど
それからおそらくジェットエンジンも付いているとは思いますけどね
でもいきなり垂直に上がったり降りたりすることはできる
垂直に上がるのは簡単で
垂直に降りるのはものすごい技術
難しいんですけど これで事故があって
あって またいろいろ改良したっていう話でね
改良したっていうことは
おそらく操縦士の能力向上した
だから垂直に上がるのは一番簡単です
問題は降りるのは大変です
あの滑走路で走っていることとは違います
滑走路でもやっぱり降りるのは一番大変難しいんだからね
で とにかくすごい技術ですね
日本にもまた配備する計画です
では 私はそれを見ながら考えたのは
こんなすごい技術能力っていうのは一般人にはアウト
軍人だけ だから科学の恩恵っていうのは軍人だけ
軍人が誰のために働いているかというと
何人かの人々のためでしょうに
国民のために働いている軍人がいません
だからすごい飛行機でしたけど
飛行機というんですか
あんなのは 飛行機じゃないんですね
一応ヘリだそうですけどね
だから性格悪いというかね
まあやっぱり一般人にはね
そういう技術は入ってこないんですね
軍艦と見たらね すごいもんでしょ
人間の能力から見れば
しかし 一般人には何の恩恵もないんです
いかに人を殺すかと 殺すのは一般人を殺すんです
だから敵を殺すと思ったとしても勘違いです
殺されるのは一般人なんです
軍隊にお金を払っている人々なんです
だからこの性格が悪いんだから
人類のために頑張るということは毛頭ないでしょう
人類のためじゃないんです
怒り憎しみのためなんです
だから現代社会にしても
ものすごく問題 問題 問題
問題 一般人にもそこはもう感染しますから
経済世界でね 競争しなくちゃいけないし
それで損得を考えなくちゃいけないし
だから仲良くしないんですね
それで各家族になっちゃうし
その方が儲かります 自分の給料で自分だけで食べていられるぞということで
大きい家族で親戚同士で生活していたのに
これがまずいと 親戚同士で仲良く生活しちゃうと
自分の給料は自分だけで使えなくなっちゃうんですね
必要なところでお互い協力しなくちゃいけないんですね
これで恐ろしい気持ち悪い人々が出てきて
私は別居するぞと 自分だけで家を借りて
それで夫婦だけで生活したりして
それで子育てはできなくなるんですね
今日テレビで今日も言ったんですけど
この今はもう子育ていろいろ問題あるんだと
子育て悪いんだと下手やとお母さんたちはと言ってますけど
別に昔のお母さんたちは上手でしたではなかったんだと
まあいいこと言ったんですね
昔のお母さんたちも同じことでしたと
しかし 昔はお母さん一人だけで子供の面倒見てわけじゃないんだと
家族以外みんなお互い仲良くしていたんだから
問題を負けなかったと
だから昔のお母さんたちは子育ては上手でしたっていうことではないんだと
広島の方で何とかこの子供たちに
家族以外の人々ともちょこっと付き合ってもらおうかなと
そういう対人関係でしたっけ？対人能力
対人能力も特別に学ばなくちゃいけないことになっているんです
で 私みたいな原始人から見ればおかしいのいいところなんですけど
人間というのは人間と一緒にいるんだから
もう生まれてからもう対人関係なんですけど
特別に学校で学ぶという
おかしいんだけど 我々は逆笑われるんで
これ原始人だからそう言うんであってとかね
もう高度な社会ではね
それは大事なポイントだよと
いうふうに逆笑いされますね
だから私はね 子供っていうのは村でみんなでそうでなくちゃいけないと説法では言いますけど
みんな笑っちゃうでしょうね
そんなアホなことっていうね
しかし 専門家言ってますからね
もうそれなりの 笑っていられないんです
それでこの中学校の子供たちが月3回
小学生に連れて学校に連れて行って
各クラスで子供たちにも担当を分けてあげて
この宿題を助けてあげてくださいと
みんなちゃんとプログラムを作っていくんですよ
それでうまくいかなくて
もう子供はいつでも中学生にももう助けを求めるんで
話しかけて これどうすればいい？どうすればいいか
じーっと待ってるんです
どうすればいいでしょうかとかね
言葉をかけられないんです
別に内容をわかってないわけじゃないんですよ
ただ なんとかゲームなんですけど
このビンゴみたいなゲームで
子供たちはこのマスの中で数字を書くんですよ
そうすると中学生の子供でカード見せるんです
掛け算なんですね 例えば3掛ける4だったら
自分が最初から書いたのマスの中に10にあったならば
そこを色を塗ってOKにする
一人の子が7書いてあったんですね
7の場合はなかなか出にくいんですね
だから一回しかないんですね
例えば 12書いた子にとってはチャンスがたくさんあります
勝てるチャンスが  7書いた子にはたった一つしかないんで
そこで中学生がそのカード
そのカードを作っているかどうかわからないしね
それで何人か子たちが自分で考えてマスを書けなくなっちゃって
で 男の子を助けに来た子供
なんとみんなじーっと待ってるんですね
だから本人が真面目に考えてますけど
自分で数字書いてあげれば簡単に書いてあげられますけど
それはやってはいけないし
子供の授業だから子供は自分で書かなくちゃいけない
しかし 何も書けない子にどう助けてあげればいいかということ
だからすごく緊張しちゃったとかね
すごく嫌になったと思う
子供が一生懸命聞いたり聞いたりするのに
自分は何も言うことができなかったとかね
やっぱりこの対人関係も学ぶ羽目になっちゃったというね
だからそういう方法しか今残ってないんですよ
だから核家族でしょうし
子供には親しか人間知る人間はいないし
親も家にはいないし だからそれで自然破壊でしょ
結局はシステムそのものが壊れているんですね
決して母親には子育てはできません
母親父親だけには 人間ですからね
相手が そう簡単じゃないんです
だからたくさんの人々が手分けして
あらゆる側面で育てなくちゃいけないんですね
対人関係といえば 年寄りから子供までたくさん人間だからね
それ全部母親にも教えられませんだからね
だからそのシステムはもう壊れちゃったんですね
だから結局は自然に簡単に生きていられるシステムがあったんですけど
それは壊して壊していく
だから愚か者には決まってます
幸福を壊していくんだからね
楽に生きることだけ壊して壊して壊して壊していくんですね
発展によって 言いながらものすごい楽だ
楽だとまた言うんですよ
何にも楽じゃないんだけど
現代生きるっていうことは
しかし ものすごく自慢げに
こんな楽な世界はあるわけないでしょって言うんです
言いながら一つも上手くいってないんですよ
結局は だから それは明確にこの人類の発展
向上を見ると 本当に向上しているのかというと
破壊なんですね 命の破壊
物は変わります 実験室に行ったら
もう億単位の機械いっぱい並べてありますよ
しかし 学生はまあ 5人とか 6人とか
計算できませんから 一人の学生にどれぐらいお金かかっているのかと
その人はそれぐらいお返し世界にするのかと
そこでそういう 1,000万円の機械であって
未開発の機械だから もう半年でまた改良して新しいものになるでしょ
また買い替えなくちゃいけないんです
前の機械はもうゴミ もう使えない
どれほど破壊か損かというと
でもありがたいことに数学できませんだからね
数学者にも 一人の人間にどれぐらい
特に理科系のお金かかっているのかと
では その人々は人類のため何かやっているのかと
国文学やっている人は最低歌一つでも作って出版するんだからね
それを読んで楽しくなるんですよ
すごい良い本ができているんだよとかね
それで読んで人々はどれほど安らぎを感じるかというと
何とか賞を取ったでしょ
何年前で この高校生の女の子がね
小説を書いて だからみんな読んで喜んで楽しかったんですね
すごいこと貢献していますよ
人間に安らぎを貢献しているんだからね
しかし 文学だから立場がないわ
認めてくれないわ バカにされるわ
それでいいんです それで合間になりませんだからね
ですから この経典で言っているポイントはね
人間が学ぶより先に性格を学ぶべきだよということが私は大事だと思いますよ
何を学ぶべきかというと
やっぱり良い人間になることを学ぶべきなんです
それ言うと笑われますけどね
そんなこと置いておいて
東大に入ることに頑張ればいいんじゃないかっていうのは
普通の愚か者の考え方なんですね
世間がはっきり言う 悪人になれと
悪人が成功するぞという話なんです
悪人が成功するんですけど
ある意味ブッダにはその人まで自分自身でも破壊するんだよと
他人を破壊することは忘れたって
自分自身でも破壊するんだよと
結局は誰しもが人間に死ぬんですよ
人間として失格者で とにかく仏教の特色として覚えておくといいんですけど
親切だと 慈悲だと あれこれだと仏教は言いますけどね
一切の生命に対する慈しみとかね
しかし 性格悪い人には教えることはやめるんです
仏教の慈しみというのは
すべての生命に良い性格を教えてあげるんです
その場合は性格悪い人に教えてあげなくちゃあかんからね
その場合は区別しません
性格悪いんだったら これは厳しくいろいろいろいろ言って性格直るようには言います
しかし 知識を教えてくれと
仏教の真理を教えてくれというのは断ると
瞑想さえも断るんです
先に性格が必要なんです
なぜかというと 教えることが慈悲の行為じゃないんです
その人が 例えば瞑想でちょこっとでも能力身についたらどうするかわからない
そういう人に限ってとにかく踏ん張って
ある程度なんとか能力身につくんです
そういった時点でもう世界に迷惑
みんなの道を閉ざす やがて自分も破壊
ということになるんです
だから実際世界では生き残るのは本当は知識人じゃないんです
優しい性格の人は結構生き残るんです
勉強丸っきりしたことがなくても
性格的に信頼できる人は生き残るんです
本当のところは しかし
世間はそれは認めません
だから世間認めないんだからといって
世間が認めないならば事実に決まっています
世間が認めるならば それは嘘であることはもうはっきりしています
みんなそう言ってるんだと言ったら
もう間違いに決まっています
いつでもみんなそうやってるんだ
みんなそう言ってるんだっていうふうなことで走っちゃうでしょうに
その時点で本人にはもうもう何もできない
束縛されている 愛する人形ということになっても証拠ですからね
自分が人間としてもう全部失格であるということを自分で言ってますけどね
だからみんなやっていることは正しいということは成り立ちませんよ
なぜならば みんながすごい知識人で
少々頭が悪いということになりますからね
普通はすごい桁違い 知識人っていうのは少数派なんですけど
何でしょうかね あれは
だから何でも因果法則で見なくちゃいけないんですよ
ある時はみんなの意見を聞いた方がいいということもあるし
ある時はみんなの意見を聞いてはいけない場合もあります
仏教は昔からそれをはっきりしています
仏教の場合は これは大乗仏教でもどこでも
それは昔からはっきり決まっています
ある時はみんなの意見は聞く
ある時は絶対聞きませんと
で これは道元禅師の弁道話っていうところかなと思いますけどね
エピソードがあって質問されちゃって
このはっきり答えはあの人にできません
だから出してはないんですけど
ものすごい頭が変ですからね
ガチャガチャガチャガチャあれこれ何でもかんでも言うだけでね
質問がこの自分が出家して修行したいんだという質問で
しかし 一人っ子で 親を母親がいるんだと
母親も病弱で だから自分が出て行ったら母親が死ぬかもしれませんと
しかし自分が出家して修行したいんだという
どうすればいいかということでね
で それにもガチャガチャガチャガチャ道元禅師も
これは質問本意出された質問じゃなくて
中国のケースを分析しているところなんですけどね
まあ何とかして出家する方が正しいと
言いたいんですよ それはすごい回り道で言うんです
で 回り道で言っても 本当にそれは答えと分かっているならばサッと言うでしょうと思いますけど
本人もそんなに分かったわけでもなくて
一応分析するんですね
やっぱり それは義務であるでしょうとね
母親の面倒を見ることはね
母親の面倒見が出て行ったなら
母親が食べるものがなくて死ぬので
それはとんでもない悪ですよと
それからまた分析して
次のケース考えちゃうと
本人が出家したいと 坐禅組みたいと
いわゆる解脱を目指したいということですからね
それを邪魔しているのは誰ですかというと
母親でしょうと それで一人の悟りに邪魔して
母親に何かいいことはあるのか？という論理なんです
私が死ぬまで私に食べ物を持ってこいと
解脱するんじゃないぞという話になりますからね
食べ物を持ってあげたっても
どうせ老人でしょうし
もうどんどんどんどん体が壊れて壊れて死ぬだけのことでしょうに
だからどうすればいいでしょうかと
息子一人 息子が母親死ぬ羽目に入れちゃうと
これは人間としてはもう失格
とんでもない 重罪になる
重罪犯せませんよと言って
母親の面倒見たんだからと言って
その子供の離脱の道が妨げちゃうと
そういうことで まあ曖昧な結論で出してますけど
結局しかし 読む人には自分で判断しなさい
ところまではデータは
論では一応分析はしてあります
法然寺は自分ではこういう判決やというふうには出しません
判決に至るところまで一応喋っているんです
それで 番目にステージから言うのは
では逆に 母親があんた出家したければしてくださいと言ったならばどうなるのかと
というと 母親がすごい苦しい羽目になりますよと
しかし なぜ母親が苦しむのかと
あるいは他人のお世話になったりとか
あるいは乞食になったり
どうか分かりませんからね
なぜ苦しむのかというと
一人の人には仏道に歩み寄るようにしてあげたんだからなんです
ですから それですぐ早死になってもね
それどういうことかと
何のために死ぬのかというと
いうところで セットで説明して終わっているんだから 3
番目ではもう結論は出しているんです
一応 それで母親が決めるべきことではないかと
もう母親には出家しなさいということは決め以外は判決できませんよ
そうすると自分の命は危ないんですけど
しかし それはすごいことではないかと
ということで そのセクションの場合は
世間の話は聞かない 仏教は
出家したいと子供が言うと
どんな親もとんでもない
なんということ 世間の常識ではないか
結婚して子供を作ったり
孫を作ってくることは
親の唯一の期待ではないかと
偉そうなことを言うんです
それってすごいことでしょうか？とは誰も考えていません
誰でもやっていることでしょうに
しかし 世間は 例えば親を親孝行しないで
世間で自分の立場を作るために
大金持ちになるために
大政治家になるために
大権力者になるため 親をまるっきり無視してもう頑張って
とりあえず褒めちゃうんですね
あるいは帆船に乗って帆船というんですか
あれ 機械ついてないボートは
帆船に乗って世界一周するぞと
すごくお金かかるんですけどね
それで家の土地を売っても
親をもう何と言いますか
肩代わりというんですかね
して借金取っても悪口言いませんね
で それで 1,000万もっとお金なくなっちゃって
例えば途中で諦めたらお金も戻ってこないし
誰もお金なくなるだけなんですと
その場合 自慢げにしゃべる
同じ人が親の面倒見てやれませんだからね
もう勝手にしろ 私は出家すると言っちゃうと
ものすごく非難する それは世間の思考なんです
その子親孝行しているのかって
それはもういい しなくていいよ
自分はもう子供のためならもう献身的に何でもやります
偉そうなこと その子供はじゃあ瞑想して
とんでもやめろよ それだけはと
親孝行すること仕事ではないかと
仏教って何やと 親孝行もしさせない仏教はね
ということになるんです
素晴らしいですよ 思考は
とにかく良い人間になることだけはもう頑固と断固徹底に反対するんです
世界は それがそうなってます
それで そういう思考があった国々も次から次へとすごく恐ろしく壊すんですよ
お説教させていますからね
アドバイスするんです
女性は自由であるべきとか
スリランカの自分の国が最近法律で禁止しちゃったんです
子供が 6歳  7歳までかな
以下の子供がいる女はもう出稼ぎに外国行ってはいけませんと
子供がいるんだったら
これにまああの恐ろしい団体がありますね
あれ あの 何て言いますか
あれが  グリーンピース
ん？ 日本人にはグリーンピースが一番怖い
いや あの人権団体  アムネスティ
アムネスティ そこは言うは言うはこの NGO のね
あのキリスト教の NGO
何人か入って国をハチャメチャにしているんですよ
言うは言うはもうもう裁判までかけてやると
裁判までかけたりとかね
とんでもないことやと
もう原始的なこと 自分言ってる本人の国々で女に自由があるのかと聞きたいんですけど
女が自由がありすぎて
もう人類が破壊しちゃったんだから
自分の国がそういう風に法律作ったんです
ものすごい社会問題になってるんですよ
もう今も大人になっていて
もう親に育てられたことはなくて
すごい犯罪に走ったりとか
これ犯罪はもうものすごい
ある人がもう今もう 10歳になっていてね
まあ自分が小さい時 自分を置いたおばさんのところに捨ててしまってね
母親が外国に行ったんだと
金儲けに  それっきりものすごい
もう 10年ぐらい経って何とか帰ってきたんですけど
本人がもう母親のことまるっきりもう興味なくて
ほとんど女たちが子供と旦那を捨てていくんですよ
金儲けに行って５  6年
もうもう奴隷みたいに仕事
あれ本当？あのSEX SLAVE という言葉ありまして
この性の奴隷 中東でしょ
行くの だからイスラム以外の人間っていうのは動物扱いですよ
飛行機から降りた途端
パスポート全部奪う で
ある女の人がこの行った日からものすごくこの虐待されましたと
あのものすごいひどく殴ったり蹴ったりして
この男たちのこのSEX SLAVEとして使ったりして
彼女は逃げたんです 走って警察署のところ逃げちゃったんです
逃げた途端 家の旦那がこの人は家のものを盗んだんだよと言って訴えたら
それでもう即裁かれてもう罰
自分の訴えはもう受け取りませんと
あんた嘘を言ってるんだと
家のものを盗んできたんだと
何を盗んだのかと もう家から逃げた人でしょうに
そんなこと簡単に言えるでしょう
何か物をなく隠しておいてね
これは盗まれたと言えば
それだけの話で 隣の家に上げれば
これちょっと置いておいてくださいと
それだけのことでしょうに
どうってことはないし
だからそういう恐ろしい
法律はそういうふうになってます
その国々ではね まあそういういろんなことがあって
ある記事でね そういう人々は何年かいてから
この空港で冷蔵庫やらテレビやらいろんな品物を買って
全部荷物を持って外へ出られますよ
外へ出たら誰もいないんだと
もう家族も誰も だから帰ってきても家族は仲良くはうまくいかないんです
たまにある日 何人か知ってますけど
もう帰ってきて まあ二
三ヶ月後にまた契約されてまた出て行っちゃうんです
だからもう狂っちゃってもそこまで狂うのかと
だから政府はもうあんた方よりはもう次の世代はしっかり育てなくちゃいけないんだと
いうことで もう子供 小さい子供がいるんだったら外国も禁止と
それにもうすっごい反対していますけどね
でもいくら反対したっても
これは変えないと思いますけどね
自分の目がね これエンジニアでね
もうすごい仕事をしていて
結婚して妊娠しちゃったんです
そしたら即仕事辞めちゃった
で かなりの給料でね もう旦那の給料だけでは苦しいと思いますけどね
だからみんなね 我々家族で子供を育ててますから
もう心配することないんだから
もうあんた仕事しなさいよと
あの子は私ね 私は聞いたんです
なんでみんな養ってくれてるでしょうと
せっかく勉強したんだからね
私の子って あのね 子供には母親が必要ですよと
それはお金で買えると思ってるんですか？と
怒られちゃったんです
だから一生懸命全部捨てて
子供のためにもう だからそれは
それは正しいんです 仏教的なんです
これ一番大事な仕事はそれであって
恐ろしい人間は育てるんじゃないんです
[背景音楽]お隣の子もなんか男の子がいて
すごい性格が悪くて もうヒステリーで神経質で
もう管理できない で すっごい親と喧嘩するは
もう我々とは何のこともないんですけどね
それでもすごい暗くてね
信じられないほど 自分の人生の中でもね
嫌な奴が生まれたなと私思ったりもしたんですけど
でも一生懸命みんな協力するとはするんですけど
なかなか性格はうまくならないんですね
すごいヒステリー おもちゃなんか買ってくれたら
取ってそのままパーンって殴って壊すんです
で 問題は父親なんです
父親がまあ 1週間スリランカにいたら
また 1週間どこかへ外国行ってるんです
で 世界で回ってないところはないんですね
で 本人の仕事ですけど
仕事で まあそれぞれいろんなことに
あれ まあなんか国の政府の仕事ですけどね
いろんなところに行ったりして
それで我慢して最終的にはなんかすごい仕事がものすごく
まあ今はもうほとんどトップクラスの仕事をやってますけど
で それでもっと上に行こうんだよと
それだったらほとんどまあ 1ヶ月とか 2ヶ月ぐらいしか
もうまとめたっても スリランカに国ではいられないんですね
その時は嫁が怒ったんです
あんた永久的に出て行くか
仕事を辞めるか どっちだけにしなさいと
で 私にはね もうあんたどうでもいいんだと
しかし あなたの子供にあんた与える損害とあんたが持ってくるお金と比較になりませんよと
それで怖くなって その仕事をやめて
普通に仕事をすることにしたんです
それでもう毎日家に戻るんです
見事にあの子は何のことなくもう変わったんです
今信じられないほどすごいいい子なんです
まあニコニコ笑っているわ
父親とやり取りやっているわで
これだともう何でもかんでも二人が組んで
もう何か組合作ってるような感じで
誰にも立ち入り入りません
すごく元気に明るくなったんです
だからまあお母さんの方ももう何のことなくもう手を抜いて気楽にいます
二人にもどうぞ勝手にやってくださいと
で 子供はものすごく真剣に勉強する
もう何でもかんでも 私にも手紙出し始めたんです
今までは一言もなかったんです
すごい明るくなったんです
だから子供にはやっぱり生命は生命
それは変わらないんだ
愛情をするっていうのは必要なんですよ
だからそこを壊す現代社会なんですね
だからまだまだ残っている国々にも
この自分たちが不幸の鈍足の人
国々が金だけ見せたりしてね
飛行機の数だけ見せたりとか
軍艦見せたりして ほら
我々これほど成長しているんだぞと
で この人間関係壊せと
全て金やと だから西洋思想で言えば
子供が生まれたらそのままゴミ箱にポイ捨てにしてでも出稼ぎに行った方がいいっていう話なんです
金が大事だと だからこのいろんな面でね
この人間が謙虚で恐れ多く生きていたシステムを壊していくんですよ
だからそこはもう力強いんですよ
向こう側がもう知識があるんだから
金があるんだから 技術があるんだから
しかし 彼らがそれで人類幸福にするかというと
人類を幸福にするんじゃなくて
人類の幸福そのものが壊していくんです
だから人々を殺すためにいっぱい武器を作っても
先に死ぬのはそちらだからね
そういうことで この本当に大したことじゃないんですよ
だから世界で普通にみんなやっぱり道徳の方がね
性格の方が一番何よりも大事やということを教えればそれだけのことですよ
それがやっぱり西洋で教えてはいけないんですね
神の聖書を教えるんですけど
アメリカでもね これ良い人間になることは絶対禁止なんです
なんであれほどアメリカもね
キリスト教の聖書を教えましょうとかね
進化論はダメですよと
間違ってますよと ありえないんだと
堂々と言ってますかというと
聖書の教えっていうのはもうすごい競争を応援しているんですね
人殺しを応援しているんですね
善悪はないんです 悪はあると言うんですけど
悪は悪人がいて その人のせいだと
言うんだから恐ろしい思考なんです
なぜ世の中に悪があるのかということは全然説明ないんです
だから誰かさんのせいなんですね
それは そうなってくると悪人を潰さなくちゃあかんでしょうに
私は悪いのはあなたのせいだという話になるんです
ルシファーという悪魔を捨てても成り立ちませんね
なぜ悪があるのかという教えがないんです
だから この戦略するために
国々を潰すために 植民地化するために
すごく協力するんですね
その教えは 魔女を退治しましたし
野蛮人を退治したりもしましたし
殺すなと言いつつ殺しましょうではという
だから その教えは随分気に入られちゃって
学校でも教えてもいいんですけど
宗教は教えてなくても私も賛成ですけど
教えなくていいんですけど
宗教は関係ないんですね
良い人間であるか悪い人間であるかということには
良い人間は社会に必要であって
悪い人間は社会に必要ではないということは明らかな事実でしょうし
それでよくなるか悪くなるかということを自分で決められますよと
それで自分で決めたいんだけど
なかなか悪い人間になるしかできんやと
この環境では それで環境に問題ありますよと
子育てに問題ありますよと
学校に問題ありますよとかね
そういうふうにいかなくちゃいけないんだけどね
そういうふうにはいかないんですね
だから私は大胆なことを言っているわけじゃなくて
この知識はダメとは仏教で言ってないし
技術はダメとも言ってないし
そうじゃなくて良い人間がやりなさいと
人類の幸福のために それだけなんです
だから悪人が知識技術を持つこと自体は危ないんだと
それは俗世間の話で この
仏教でいうのは道徳の話ですね
[紙の音][背景音楽]